tratemos de calcular 39.1 menos 0 punto
794 para empezar ponle pausa al vídeo e
inténtalo por tu cuenta bien supongo que
ya lo probaste y ahora vamos a hacerlo
juntos vamos a reescribir esto 39.1
vamos a escribirlo de manera vertical
alineando los puntos decimales y las
posiciones de los números así es que
sería menos 0 en las unidades menos 0
punto 794 y ya estamos listos para hacer
esta resta ahora como restamos 4 de nada
y 9 de nada vamos a poner estos ceros
que son equivalentes a nada ya podemos
pensar en cómo hacer esta resta pero aún
tenemos el problema de cómo restar 4 de
0 y como restar 9 de 0 bueno lo que
vamos a hacer es esta décima la vamos a
expresar en términos de centésimas y en
términos de milésimas para poder hacer
esta resta hagamos eso pero
espera aún así tendríamos problemas pues
cómo le hacemos para restar 7 de 0 que
tenemos aquí entonces vamos a reescribir
las unidades estas 9 unidades las
reescribimos como 8 y la unidad que nos
sobra la vamos a escribir como 10
décimas 10 décimas y una que teníamos
son 11 décimas de estas once décimas
tomamos una nos quedan 10 y la que
tomamos la pasamos a centésimas con lo
que aquí tendríamos 10 centésimas y
finalmente una de estas centésimas nos
quedarían 9 la pasamos como 10 milésimas
ya estamos listos para hacer la resta
déjame escribirla en amarillo 10 menos 4
699 0 10 menos 7 3 bajamos el punto
decimal
8 - 0 8 y 3 - 0 3 hemos terminado el
resultado es 30 y 8.306